Did you know that it was possible for you to
apply
of acquisition of French nationalities
after 2 years on the territory ?
Yes,
it is possible.
Generally,
for
apply
of acquisition of French nationality,
you must stay in France for 5 years.
But I will give you the exception
which is recorded on the entry code,
of the stay and request of foreigners from Asia,
1 person who has studied
superior with bravo
2 years of higher education in France
can apply for nationality after 2 years.
You arrived in France as a master,
you do master in validate master 2,
validate 2 years.
As soon as your year is validated,
you make your status change the same year,
you can file your acquisition application
of your French nationality.
You don't need to justify the 5 years
lives on the territories.
If you want the list of items to provide
for the constitution
of the file,
like this video as soon as it reaches 10,000 likes,
I make you the 2nd part